once a year the divers of the town of
verb Nick head out to sea to raise
buried treasure it's a very special day
for the whole village the treasure is
sparkling wine crates of it are left for
six years at a depth of 30 metres in the
Adriatic where it's dark and the
temperature is a constant 12 degrees
Celsius the sparkling July Tina is made
with an indigenous variety of grape wine
expert marinko of luggage came up with
the underwater storage idea divine this
wine is a lovely aroma it's very
distinctive there's a hint of the sea
about it nobody else is known to let
their wine aged in the sea the vintners
of ironic want their market share to
grow especially in the European Union
did miss end the Kent family we have to
fight without competition you just go to
sleep and that's them good you have to
keep fighting you need competition we're
in Europe now isn't it open it'll be
better without Paul against a clover
this it has to be better Lupe Olivencia
miss mrs. I'm
but of Nick also boasts what is perhaps
the narrowest alleyway in the world just
43 centimeters wide at one point Couric
was called the golden island two
thousand or more years ago there are
many rocky coves along the coast and
divers love it here yeah we have the
best water quality in Europe and there
are beautiful shipwrecks right in front
of our door and caves they're all great
for diving you'll be holding pen in an
underwater landmark many divers visit is
this wreck a freighter the pelt askis
which sank in 1968 on the west side of
the island is poo nut which lies in a
sheltered Cove it's yacht harbor is
considered one of the best on the
Adriatic Dragutin jilted 50 years ago
when Croatia was still part of the
former Yugoslavia sugar marina there was
a shortage of money in materials so we
bought old train tracks and just rammed
them into the ground and laid planks
over the structure it was cheap and
stable and it's still good today the
harbor now belongs to the judge family
dragutin's son Chris a mere looks after
their customers
many come from Germany and Austria and
return year after year fun falafel at
eighty-five percent of our customers
come from other European countries own
from the start we have run our business
in accordance with high international
standards we've really been part of
Europe for centuries Yahoo the convert a
circus I'm Dragutin judge says a
fascinating place to visit especially if
you like history is the neighboring tiny
island of koh luan in the cove a few
hundred meters from pune there you'll
find franciscan monks their monastery
houses a fabulous library of ancient
books and the park is leafeon tranquil
in fact the church museum and park are
all open to the public the town of kirk
is the biggest on the island of the same
name with a population of 3,000 it too
is rich in history tour guide maroon
church tells visitors about the islands
complicated history at different times
it was occupied by the Romans Venetians
Austrians and French
polyglot there are lots of bridges
connecting houses across the lanes here
in town they were built when members of
the two families who lived there and
married each other
Kirk is Croatia's biggest island but the
country boasts at least a thousand more
so there's plenty to explore in the e
u--'s newest member state